- [Instructor] Hello readers.
The following video
contains explicit content.
Uh, okay, not in the way you're thinking.
It doesn't contain violence,
obscenity or profanity.
Or even anything that wouldn't
appear in a G-rated movie,
but it will contain explicit evidence.
Yes, we're talking about citing evidence
in literary analysis.
When you're talking about a text
and making arguments about it,
in order to successfully
build that argument,
you must make inferences
and draw conclusions.
And those must be built
on the back of evidence.
Both explicit, that is stated in the text,
or implicit or based on clues
or evidence in the text.
So your responsibility is to tie
those conclusions or
inferences back to explicit
or implicit evidence in the text.
It can't just be,
"This is a feeling I have."
It has to be, "My feeling
about this is backed up
by this specific evidence."
Say you're trying to be make an argument
in a book that the captain
of this pirate ship,
let's just say, I guess, he's a birdman.
That's what I drew, he's a birdman.
He's really unkind to the main character
in the beginning of the book,
but changes by the end of the book
and treats everyone,
including the main character
with respect and courtesy.
So I'm gonna write that my argument
is that the captain's behavior changes
towards the MC, the main character.
I have to back that
assertion up with evidence.
So how do we find those details?
First, you have to seek out parts
of the book where the captain
and the main character interact.
Then look closely at
the pros and dialogue.
What are the details
that prove your point?
Which are the strongest,
most specific details
that say, "Oh, yes, here is where
the captain is being mean.
Here is where the captain
is being respectful."
If you can't find evidence
for your assertion,
first, try searching in a
different part of the book.
Or importantly,
acknowledge the possibility
that you might have a weak argument.
Maybe it's time to start over
and find a new or
different argument to make
and find support for.
Once you've assembled your evidence
work it into your analysis.
"Captain Bigsby is dismissive
and rude to Eniola when she first joins
the crew of the pirate ship
Albatross," I might say.
And then back it up with an explicit
example of Captain Bigsby being dismissive
and rude with a page
number citation like so.
On page 34 of "To the Burbling Deep,"
Bigsby says to Eniola, "You
there, what's her name!
These portholes need to
be scrubbed yesterday.
Get to work!."
"Yes, sir, Captain," Eniola said.
"But my name is-"
"Does it look like I
care?" the captain snarled.
But by the end of the story,
when Eniola has proven her worth,
saved the day, and humbled the captain,
he treats her, and everyone around him,
with much greater respect and deference.
On page 225, after Bigsby
tends to Eniola's broken leg,
he tells her, "Eniola, that was some
mighty fine pirating you did.
You showed no fear when
you punched that kraken,
and more importantly, you showed no fear
when you stood up to me.
I was wrong, and I have been
a jerk, and I am sorry."
Now both of those examples
use explicit evidence
where Captain Bigsby is being a jerk
and then when he is
apologizing for being a jerk.
There's also implicit evidence too.
Bigsby tends to Eniola's broken leg.
So while he's not saying,
"I will take care of you
little buddy," with his words,
he is saying it with his actions.
And in that first example
when he demands that
Eniola clean the portholes,
he's not literally
saying, "I'm impatient,"
But by saying, "They need
to be scrubbed yesterday,"
as an immediately because
you already messed up,
he's implying that he's impatient.
Now there is no such book that I know
of about a kraken punching girl pirate.
But if we're lucky, my
friend Jordan will write one.
Remember to use strong
details to get good evidence.
There might be a part of
"To The Burbling Deep"
where Captain Bigsby huffs angrily
at Eniola but doesn't say anything,
and that's mean or, at least, impolite,
but it's not as strong
as him yelling at her.
So when you find the detail, ask yourself,
how does that detail related back
to your analysis or your argument.
Is it repeated?
Does that detail or detail similar to it
appear elsewhere in the text?
And if you see a lot of similar details,
how do those details prove the argument
that you're trying to make?
If you have a sense of
what the central idea
or ideas of the text is,
try to connect those details
back to that central idea and then connect
that central idea to your own argument.
I don't know what "To the Burbling Deep"
is about 'cause I made
it up 20 minutes ago.
But maybe one theme in it
is that it's important to recognize
the potential with another people.
And that can be both true for Eniola
who becomes a hero and punches
a giant octopus monster,
but it can also be true of Captain Bigsby
who occupies kind of antagonistic role
and then changes through the story.
And so we can build our
argument around that idea
that character change is possible.
Not just for the main character,
but for everybody.
So that's where I will leave you.
Remember to choose the pieces of evidence
that give you the strongest support
for your idea and if the evidence
doesn't match your idea,
you might need to change the idea itself.
You can learn anything.
David out.